après avoir construit des cochons
volants des robots et divers véhicules
meurtrière squeeze acquis l'expérience
nécessaire pour fabriquer une ultime
machine le projet dit hors ue27 wysiwys
politesse à moto aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour une seconde vidéo sur ben
y siègent
j'ai fait le véhicule dont tout le monde
rêve capable d'accomplir tout par
exemple de s'agrandir ne fait pas cette
blague jeunes délinquants sexuels de
casser les maisons
[ __ ] ça fait déjà réduit les gens que
je prends pour un ingénieur à établir ce
[ __ ] de véhicules il faut aussi option
catapulte et oui à tous quoi as tu viens
d'arrêter la boule de noël prend 1 prend
la grosse tête la boule la haye les
inactifs et ma blague
vous avez vu ou alors il n'a pas du tout
aimé elle s'est autodétruite la maison à
les autres suivante j'ai essayé de faire
un véhicule capable de terminer ce jeu
alors le but c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout
de l'allée comme ceux ci il me semble
qu'il ya des mines sur le chemin donc on
va lancer ça pour faire péter les mines
ça n'a servi à rien mais bon on va y
aller bon voilà à voir si la faiblesse
du véhicule c'est à dire qu'ils se
déplacent de manière plutôt lente
attendez on va passer par la pousse toi
jeune arbre t'agresse nous [ __ ] on y
va virage serré à gauche
[Musique]
oui j'ai mis une heure à faire un
créneau est alors un alan termine vite
voilà le projet titan est capable de
détruire une armée d'archers en moins
d'une seconde
ou de détruire un archer non c'est bon
il est détruite ou cyprès ne veut pas
j'avais peur terme à des mois des fois
elle est un peu moyenne quand même hein
il est capable de s'élever et de tirer
pour toucher les maisons du fonds on y
va on va prendre feu je suis con voilà
l'homme nul c'est moi voilà bonjour je
m'appelle lucas ou charles déjà ses
roues là ne bouge pas donc il faut il
faut modifier à tout de suite ce sera
bien mieux je pense ça tombe beaucoup
mieux voyez vous voyez pas la différence
non c'est vraiment un jeu suit pas il ya
de la passion dans ce que j c'est
incroyable ouais jamais vu aussi
passionné pour quelque chose sans
déconner collatéral et schott foot beach
ouais c'est ça mon vaisseau c'est mon
poulain [ __ ] il est né deux mondes de
montcuq au oui alors là c'est là que
vous allez voir l'efficacité du vaisseau
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta bla bla
bla bla bla tout le monde leur saveur ou
macédoine et voilà on a gagné et c'est
attendre la victoire
[Musique]
alors ça c'est le truc chiant il faut
prendre les boules et les mettre dans le
circuit là-bas souvenez vous je vais me
débarrasser s'applique à tout moment au
regard des c'est beau le petit ricochet
eux elle tombe et elle roule jusqu'à
lancer en avance pour toi on n'a plus
qu'à aller prendre celle la regarder
mais avec le bras articulé na no 4 de 8
hop là on l'a pris à aucun problème
devrait fabriquer des vaisseaux et les
vendent vraiment l'armée us pas contacté
déjà après j'ai refusé parce que voilà
je pourrais devenir commercial de pensée
pour ces cas l'argent est tous vraiment
c'est ça m'intéresse pas moi je fais
rang des vaisseaux par passion mais
c'est nul ça du non mais regardez qu'est
ce qu'on fait quand on voit ça on fait
ça allez à bientôt
le projet titan est capable aussi
d'envoyer des bombes
alors c'est plus dangereux il est vrai
qu acheter le projet tiezan détruit 80 %
de tout ça non mais attends mais nous
pouvons pour que macédoine partie aux
plats bientôt aux plats aux plats aux
plats mais là regardez regardez ans avec
deux doigts
1 et 2
aujourd'hui on attaque quand même un
certain niveau on peut le dire regardez
moi ça là en place à des galas mer mais
du coup j'ai raté quand même je pense
qu'il faut faire ça non non ça s'appelle
la touche l'artificer mauvais hymne
casse mavuba avant que j'envoie en fête
avec leurs [ __ ] de flèches regardez
moi ce petit bâtard la regarder c'est
pour ils sont tellement son c'est que
juge cliquer sur fly eolas apps est
séparable séparables hop là on va les
taper avec nos canons walla est là on
fait quoi on tire attention messieurs
dames c'était beau tout en une fois et
on n'a rien vu parce que j'étais en vue
de côté voilà très bon caméraman mais
attends mais c'est une épreuve de plus
passé avec le projet du temps ça les
valorise c'est bien comme ça sur le
marché des vaisseaux il va vraiment non
là on va galérer pour prendre l'un de
ces cubes de rondins de bois et les
mettre dans le voilà dans le dans le
cercle finalement on y va bien sûr
toujours tirer les canons dans le doute
mais non mais c'est normal c'est
jetables comme les rasoirs une fois
qu'on l'a pris qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
une pause de [ __ ] allez hop là allez
vas-y vas-y pétain oh non oui oh [ __ ]
s'est étendue à l abri des témoins comme
ça aux mondiaux qui s'ils vont faire
tuer 80% de tous les moutons mais bien
sûr si je puis me permettre
j'apporte une petite modification râlez
pas si je rajoute quelques lance flammes
par ci par là de manière à ce que
vraiment ça fasse un vrai méchoui un jeu
sans trouver le tout le vaisseau
aggravée avec la laine [ __ ] de mails
de belle gueule on dirait une bataille
navale à l'époque vous savez donc comme
dans les bateaux mais avec du feu voilà
et sur terre donc s'appuyer bataille
cheval non mauvais surprend peu dans
certaines idées de merde on va rajouter
un max de cadre ce que vous êtes prêts
enfants où c'était aulas laisse moutons
quoi [ __ ] le mais qu'elle allait les
voyages que ton jetons avec la libye
s'emballer ce texte quoi mais regardez
le il est toujours là là il a tout
compris
ah non pas tellement voyait lui passa
très belles sommes carrément regarder eu
un pic dans le cul et son ballet style
je suis scandalisée 1 au nickel ont faim
spectacle quoi accordéon jours et là on
fait encore fait nommer mais qu'avant
vous trop loin il on trouve puissance a
fait on est bloqué sur un niveau avec
des moutons quand même temps on fait une
machine de guerre après mois on fait pas
en sorte qu'ils soient créés pour dicter
des boutons attendez je vais faire la
technique mauvais joueur et il nous en
manque trois là trois petits moutons
projet titan toujours au top on l'a vu
sans aucune difficulté
oh [ __ ] c'est quoi ça il faut passer à
travers ça et ça tombait avec la
maniabilité de mon véhicule bon attentes
et on va voir diacounda du mal pour un
créneau alors la manga c'est parti si
quelqu'un ils croient qu'ils lèvent la
main tout de suite allez on y croit
[ __ ] on a le permis ou par bernard je
peux pas je peux pas oui c'est trop
grand rien et je pense qu'ils vont faire
un petit retour la base pour passer
c'est cet endroit reconstruction
véhicule c'est parti
[Musique]
tabac ceci les véhicules les plus
évoluées de la planète et bon match
alors voilà ça par contre j'avais pas
pensé mais non mais le truc qui ce recul
hervé on dira plus tard d'insectes sur
le dos quoi et si on y va comme ça en
frontal gubitsch croyons zijin mais on
va passer aucun la première en ondes à
perdre une roue sépara spa toujours ne
pas paniquer ne pas paniquer [ __ ]
attendait parce qu'il fallait que je
supprime calcutta attendait juste voir
simon ouais c'est parce que je pense que
c'est bien tu lâches y ait quoi alors là
on peut y aller faut juste pas perdre
une roue [ __ ] mais c'est leur flèche
la williamine kpt et ils sont tous tués
c'est comme gagner au loto
[ __ ] mais c'est pas mal oh là là ils
ont fait péter toutes les mines mon dieu
on passe au milieu des explosions
michael bay hashtag michael bay on est
passé au premier on passe au deuxième
front flip baby boxe pour les nuls
projet titan le revoilà
nickel on a un petit lanceur mal avant
regardez c'est parfait le domaine mais
qui s'en foutent quoi ils ont aucune
pitié c'est des guerriers à se faire ça
pour les tuer voilà ça c'est un très
bonne technique au plat j'adore trouve
que c'est une certaine méthode anti
stress quoi si oui le projet titan est
aussi prévue pour mai qu'a subie vente à
nickel mais en fait c'était dernier
niveau fait on a fini il crache face au
maître on a fini le jeu et il veut pas
nous avouer qu'on a fini qu'on est trop
fort pour lui et moi je fais du tout un
gros ego m l'agencé japonaise des objets
classés vous a plu et que vous avez
surtout aimé le projet titan cissé
cannes stp lève tôt que d'habitude
j'adore faire des petits yeux comme ça
on construit notre truc pour aqua pour
un comble j'ai à faire
j'adore les jeux comme ça ou construit
notre truc pour ensuite accomplir un
objectif c'est assez cool j'ai réussi
merci mais ça va regarder en s'auto
gentille dans leur sang tomates au genou
mais [ __ ] on se retrouve très bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo qu'un to be